it's uh Oh cramped in here so when I was
doing my reviews for black mirror
because I started on season four of that
then went back with season one and
watched all the episodes that currently
exist that I did up somebody by episode
reviews of all of them more than a few
people told me that if I liked black
mirror I should check out inside number
nine now very few people told me
anything else other than that like some
people were kind of vague as to you know
it's not sci-fi the way that a black
mirror is and but they sort of made a
tonal connection to it and I didn't look
up very much other than the fact that
there aren't all that many episodes of
this thing there are only a half-hour
long and I figured let me get one other
thing knocked off my to-do list before
we get into the new season of television
and you know and I have a ton more stuff
to keep up to keep up with as it airs so
I have now started watching inside
number nine and I'm Dan dive started at
the beginning which is sardines now I'm
gonna go spoiler free for as long as I
can
I am eventually gonna talk spoilers I
mean the short version is that it is
humorous it is clever
it is well-constructed especially for
where it's going it has its little
twists and turns and I don't really want
to say anything else other than that
because I think in many ways a bit like
black mirror it is best experience with
as little prep as possible you know just
go in and experience it and I and here's
the other thing unlike say the first
episode of black mirror which was
national anthem that one was one I
actually had to like warn people
well not warn people off from but be
like look you very well might hate this
and and if and if you're the kind of
person who would hey
this it could be almost traumatizing to
watch this isn't quite that extreme
that's not to say that everyone will
like this nobody I hate this I'm sure
this is very much not to everybody
sensibilities but if you don't like it
it's not going to disturb you down to
your very core the way that National
Anthem did on Black Mirror
so with that established I would
recommend it especially if you did enjoy
Black Mirror if you haven't checked out
inside number nine now I say that only
being one episode in but it's a strong
opening and now I'm going to talk in
more detail including spoilers so there
you go sardines so like I said I knew
very little about this going in and I do
know that you know they recycle some of
the actors but it's it's it is you know
a unique contained story every time it's
an anthology show like black mirror is
the I it's funny because I don't know if
sardines this is something that's
actually played much in in the UK and in
Britain but over here in the US I think
I I feel like I've heard of it like
maybe once or twice but I didn't need to
know what the game was to sort of get
how it worked that that happened I got
that pretty smoothly and so initially
it's just this this exercise in
awkwardness and the thing is it really
shows the caliber of the writing because
usually I hate embarrassment humour and
most Awkward humor leans heavily on
embarrassment humor that's what makes it
you know awkward
whereas this the awkwardness felt much
more real it felt much more genuine it
didn't feel as contrived it didn't feel
as forced it was just these people some
of whom like being around each other
some of whom don't some of whom have a
history with each other some of whom
don't just crammed into this tights
bass and yes that is an awkward
situation to be in
and it's funny and I'll come back to you
know more about this when I talk about
the ending but I was I actually found
myself sympathizing with the in quite a
bit who's the character who's everyone's
like oh man he's he's super boring and
he oh he's the first one in the closet
and I'm sorry the wardrobe and you know
he keeps trying to sort of interject
ever-so-slightly into these
conversations and he says things that
just sort of stop the room den everyone
just kind of looks at him and it's not
like it's not like well except for maybe
one thing that he says is it's almost
never a total record scratch like what
the hell
usually it's just more of a boy that
just kind of killed the conversation
didn't it and I really sympathize with
him because I've had my moments where
I'm not sure if I've done that but it
certainly felt like I have and and I
think what really sold it is you got the
sense that whenever he opened his mouth
and he said something that just made
everyone else be like you you oh you got
the sense that he had really thought
about that like he really thought that
was the right thing to say that was a
good idea to say that but it just wasn't
and man I felt for the guy in that part
a little bit less at the very I mean
sympathize but hmm okay we'll get to the
end of so as the characters add in and
and it was I thought I was gonna be
really annoyed with unfortunately this
characters name I'm now losing but the
the flamboyant partner I was initially
annoyed with but it what took the
cursing because he was very he was very
stereotypical
and I'm not gonna say people like this
don't exist but he he's the he's the
kind of character who you know upon
realizing that he was gay wasn't just
gonna be gay he was gonna be fabulous
and
it's such an affectation and again I'm
not saying people don't act like that
but it's something that tends to it can
often annoy me not always but it can
often irritate me in real life and it
really tends to irritate me in media and
entertainment but it helped that like
his partner who was way more
straight-laced very buttoned up and we
find out why later
had a few moments of just sort of saying
to him like look cut it out and doing it
with a tone that says when these two are
alone and it's just the two of them he's
not like this
not to this degree he cranks it up for
an audience and you get that from the
annoyance of this other character and
that kind of took the curse off what I
was seeing cuz if it felt like gay it
added a bit of depth of that character
and actually it was kind of like that
across the board cuz I remember thinking
initially are we really just gonna be
stuck in this one a room in this one
wardrobe and we're just gonna keep
piling people in they're gonna do that
for a half hour yeah and it works
because characters who appear
superficial at first get a little deeper
we get a little more about them
characters who start out as a joke like
stinky John we get enough information
about them that suddenly that's not a
joke anymore and the way then and the
whole thing does kind of pivot on a dime
but it does it does lay the groundwork
for that to actually work you know just
the little bits of no we don't talk
about that the little hints of you know
no no no sort of bits and it's all I'd
behind this this facade of oh you know
oh it's all well and good you know stiff
upper lip and but there is its and it's
not like oppressive but there is that
sort of slight underlying there's stuff
here that they don't talk about and that
kind of runs throughout and so it does
work at the end when we get the end
reveal about the
father about the patriarch about his
proclivities towards young boys and then
of course we get the twist and I I love
what a twist can turn on a single line
and work because so often twists that
are basically revealed with a single
line of dialogue are the dumbest twists
more often than not but this is a case
where one line of dialogue and all of a
sudden you go oh and you realize what's
going on I also really like the moment
that they chose to end it on that we see
what's in or Phillip pip is planning to
do we understand why he's doing it but
we don't see him go through with it I
like that ending and not that I'm saying
I need to believe that he doesn't but I
think actually showing him following
through on that to the what would have
been a little bit gratuitous and I think
it lets the moment hang in the air
better ending it where they did just on
a fade to black and I am now really
excited to see what else this show has
in store so I'm hoping you've seen
sardines because while I I still left
out some details on the off chance that
somebody was watching this even watching
this all the way through even though
they haven't seen it but yeah I hope you
have so what do you think about it what
do you think about this show in general
don't spoil anything in the comments for
me for other people you know just don't
but you know your thoughts on this show
in this episode in general whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you own it you know
all the stuff that you can do so I you
don't even need me to tell you I do have
a patreon I'll mention that but there's
links for that and all that other usual
gobbledygook it's all down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]